ici là depuis que tu es là il y en a
combien qui t'ont draguer a franchement
oui dit le franchement on s'en bat
jamais à toi tu vas à la fois une
tutelle sur ces huit toi m'a dit étonné
y compris les techniciens tous et pas de
sécurité ne t'a pas draguer franchement
dans l'équipe personne n'attendait ci
est en fait personne moi c'est vrai nom
est hébergé dans l'équipe personne vous
voulez voter machines non cash et
orléans bleus montrent pas alors voilà
comment la regarde
ah oui alors il ya bernard montiel est
battu de lambeaux pas à quel point qui
font pas tout le monde
[Applaudissements]
les scientifiques sont propagées
beaucoup trop bas oui bah le nom basque
oui oui oui ici à force de travailler
avec les gens plus c'est une émission où
on donne tout ce qu'on a on se voit
avant on connaît les gens moins une
autre époque si j'avais été célibataire
et si cette personne avait été
célibataire il y aura quelqu'un dans
l'équipe que j'aurais courtiser une
manière noble mais déterminé ce qui est
d'isabelle vous êtes révélations cette
révélation est énorme il ya là c'est
chez vous ah oui à temps parce qu'elle
vient de dire que vous lui plaisez lui
l'a dit s'il était si ça met à l'eau
fait tout ça c'est impossible on pour
dire des conneries et mot sur n'importe
quoi et on se dit tous par là moi je
veux la vérité l'a dit la vérité moi à
barr delphine kelly bas tout le monde
christine et isabelle ratiba de mardi ah
oui isabelle ça serait plus amical je
vous d'accord benjamin castaldi si vous
étiez célibataire mais c'est pas mon cas
je ne suis pas ces débats n'en est rien
et permet aussi la wii a été très
honnête honnêtement si tu les terres
répond comme ça ça veut dire qu'elle
regarde alors voilà on s'en fout
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
moi j'aurais pu s'étirer
ouais pas par une productrice par
exemple dans l'équipe agathe à bâle par
exemple merci monsieur vanneste
on vous sait que c'est matthieu
delormeau vous moi c'est vous mais vous
n'avez pas dit si l'établissement était
sachez que je peux en acheter les
shoppings mondiale a pour numéro un
gilbert d'un an de 0 2 patrick sébastien
la libre et j'adore ça passe avec moi en
revanche je vous dis juste ça en une
phrase à trois reprises j'ai pas donner
dans le boulot mais à trois reprises je
me suis trouvée coincée dans les
toilettes pendant que le patron de
l'entreprise dans laquelle je bossais à
l'époque lui était occupé avec une jeune
femme dans l'air de dans l'ère des
toilettes et mois coincée dans les
toilettes dont je pouvais pas sortir
parce que huit en train de faire ses
petites affaires à une jeune femme sait
qu'on aura la glace il c'est con parce
que l'émission avait un super vite
[Rires]